[Music]
hey buddy I don't know if this will good
to you I hope so actually I don't
because it'll probably mean I'm dead
which you may not feel too busted up
above sorry I got to keep this short you
may never forgive me for what I took
from you and I can't go back in time and
fix all the mistakes I made but maybe I
could leave something for the future a
legacy and you'll realize it was all
worth
it
[Music]
what
w
[Music]
a
I got
the another FL
monar was there in San
Francisco when the whole city was com
down these guys were taking pictures
like they'd been waiting for
it you think that your father was
working for them this stuff wasn't as
safe who are they what's
Monarch there's a
new this is the world we live in
monsters are an inescapable reality and
it's those files belong to us and they
are more important than you could
possibly
imagine there
[Music]
this is going to give me
nightmares now you can choke down that
Monarch
lie about your father disappearing
with or we can find out what really
[Music]
happened before it's too
late oh my God go go go this world it's
not ours believe
me is so much more vast than we could
possibly
imagine these monsters and Monarch have
taken everything from
me no
more the world is on fire if you want to
save millions of lives we can use some
[Music]
help